professor Solana members of the German
parliament of the torture Bundestag
ladies and gentlemen the digital
community has a lot of birthdays to
celebrate this year twenty years of the
Internet as we know it almost ten years
of Facebook and Skype which have been
bringing together people from all over
the world these and other innovations
have changed the way we communicate we
work and indeed live and Stanford has
been at the heart of this revolution
Stanford is where the best and the
brightest come together from all over
the world this is where outstanding
researchers and scientists put their
ideas and visions into practice where
they come up with groundbreaking
inventions this is where ideas are
translated into reality and this is a
birthplace of the digital economy some
like to call stand for the cradle of
Silicon Valley but Stanford is much more
than that it is the cradle of the
digital revolution and what's even more
important within a short space of time
what began as small startups operating
in garage turned into global players
Fred Terman
one of the fathers of Silicon Valley and
professor here in Stanford capture the
spirit of the Bay Area when he said
there wasn't much here and the rest of
the world looked awfully big now a lot
of the rest of the world is here so it
was technology and Internet and
companies from Silicon Valley
that got the ball rolling and they have
been at the epicenter of a digital
revolution which started right here in
California they are driven by the motto
think big and we are here because we
want ourselves to be inspired by the
unique spirit of the valley the west
coast of California set the pace for the
international startup scene and at the
German Minister of economics and
technology I think I can safely say that
you are a role model for startups
everywhere in the world and as you know
Germany has a thriving economy one of
the strongest in the world my guess is
that the first thing that comes to your
mind when you think about the German
economy is probably our automotive
sector I saw the advertisement in the TV
here in the valley
far from Luton and four-prong by Technic
in the last few days since I've been
here in the valley
I've seen it appears that German cars
are pretty popular here in Silicon
Valley as well but guess what our IT
sector and Germany is even bigger than
our automotive industry and our IT
sector is becoming more and more
integrated with other strong sectors
mechanical engineering logistics and of
course our automotive industry that's
because we want both a strong
manufacturing base and a strong IT
sector we have long understood that the
digital sector poses no threat to
traditional industry or vice-versa
on the contrary IT is going to make our
manufacturing sector more agile speed up
production create growth and give us a
competitive edge
so the next advertise would be
farfegnugen and force problem though I T
so I'm absolutely certain that the
future is all about bringing the digital
economy into manufacturing that's not
only good for the industry and not only
good for the IT sector it's good for
both and it's more than good it's the
future of the economy I'm not only
talking about Germany here now I'm
talking about the future of the global
economy and as a minister I want Germany
to be ready to embrace this future we
have one of the strongest economies just
mentioned it to you and what we need now
is an even stronger IT seen in our
country that's why I creating a new
better ecosystem for startup companies
in Germany we are setting up programs
tailored to the needs of high tech
entrepreneurs who want to start a
business from university we have joined
forces with some major German companies
they've created the high tech startup
fund and we have launched a special
incubator right here in the valley the
German Silicon Valley accelerator it
helps German startups to access the
American market and find investors from
the US and I'm convinced there are three
major issues for the German economy by
the end of the decade we want to triple
the amount of venture capital available
to startups to double the number of
annual startups in the digital economy
and we want to get Germany into the top
three of international start
applications at the moment we are in a
sixth place I think that's not enough
and we do have the potential to make all
this happen our startup scene is already
attracting a great deal of interest
internationally the most impressive
example is Berlin it acts as a magnet
for more and more young IT enterpreneurs
who make the city their favorite base
and that's hardly surprising Berlin has
much to offer a buzzing cultural sector
affordable rents excellent
infrastructure and all this and the very
heart of Europe and we have a strong
startup scene all over our republic but
Berlin is a synonym for the German
startups all this explains why we
already have a strong IT startup culture
and why the scene is becoming
increasingly international we are glad
about this development but we want to go
further we want more of all of this our
motto is think big think better think
Berlin and almost exactly 50 years ago
your president john f kennedy said those
famous words ich bin ein Berliner every
German knows these words and today 50
years later we now know what he really
meant by that and I'm convinced his
vision is now in Berlin and Germany our
political mission and received an
all-time record number of applications
by young startup companies who wanted to
come with me
here into the Silicon Valley you can't
even imagine
just how many wanted to come believe me
all of these entrepreneurs sitting there
would have been prepared to swim the
Atlantic and walk across America just to
be here with you today and yes today we
are here 100 startup entrepreneurs the
cream of the crop and just talk to them
and you'll get an idea of how cool our
Germany startup scene really is and
indeed how cool
Germany's my father told me that our
family our European neighbors and
partners and our best friends outside
Europe the United States of America so
the great nation on the one hand and the
coolest nation in the world on the other
and today's Germany is a country of
boundless opportunity everyone is
welcome everyone who wants to make it in
Germany and process Alana mentioned few
light maybe my living it's a little bit
of proof of that so you're right I was
born 1973 in Vietnam why the Vietnam War
I lost my parents in Vietnam War and
then my father was Captain at the German
army aviation decided to adopt me from a
Catholic orphanage after the divorce I
was few years old we lived together my
father and he gave me the opportunity to
go to school to go to college to make my
medical doctor in heart surgery then I
went into politics became a member of
parliament chairman of the parliamentary
group state minister for economic slave
and Transport Federal Health Minister
chairman of the free Democratic Party
now vice-chancellor I minister for of
economics and technology so it's a very
fast way and it's normal for Germany
because if you would ask my father if he
is proud of me
he would say yes I'm proud of my son I
brought of Philip and if you would ask
me Philip
I would say that's not the question
maybe I wake up every morning and I'm
not a reminding proud of my life but
every morning I'm thankful to Germany
because my home country gave me all
these opportunities and not only for me
but for all our companies for example as
well Germany is a country of boundless
opportunity a country of success stories
and that's why we have come here today I
invite all of you maybe your German not
surprised but the Alice to come to my
home country and write your own success
stories you have the opportunity of
shaping our future economy our future
industry in a country where there's no
limit to what you can achieve all you
need is some brilliant ideas and I've
have had the opportunity to be here two
months ago and as a gift from the German
students here in Stanford I got this
shirt and there you can find your motto
d lift
they are freiheit wait it's a German so
that is Germany 2013 a country in which
Duluth deaf high height be it the
coolest nation in the world very well
welcome to you thank you for your
attention
one question from you I'm interested in
your perspective and and and maybe you
can share your insights to what extent
you believe that
and we're actually does sort of Germany
as a as a whole as industry and the
educational system has a competitive
edge within sort of the global economy
what what are they sort of peculiar
aspects where you think that sort of
collectively what Germany has in terms
of education infrastructure and have for
for industry has actually a competitive
edge that is competitive with for
example what is coming and going on in
the valley the year 2013 means now yes
we have a competitive edge but we need
much more money for infrastructure but
the next few years we have a great issue
and that's to come to a stable budget so
that's our first issue and then the next
is investments for example in
infrastructure I think we have a very
good education system Gulen system is
very good but we can learn from
universities maybe how come too much
more entrepreneurship in our
universities but the most important pot
topic for the German economy is a
question of what I mentioned the merge
between classical industry on the one
hand and the IT sector on the other at
this moment 20% of our GDP growth
resides only because of our IT sector
and working in the normal industry with
IT but you want to raise these
percentage from now 20 percent up to 50
percent in the Year 2015 and I think
that is the future not only for one
industry but for the whole industry for
the machinery you need at this moment
software you need IT and the health
business you need IT as well so that
would be the future and so it's a
question of competitiveness to raise the
potential of your IT sector that is the
reason why we're here we want to have
much more such from such beautiful
startup companies and now we have nearly
nine thousand startups every year and
that's a reason why I want to develop
from nine thousand this year to eighteen
thousand in the year 2020 we need it not
only for the IT sector but for the whole
industry hi my name is anger I am a
student in Stanford and I spent six
months in Berlin last year researching
the startup scene in my experience I
think apart from infrastructure in
capital the two biggest problems that
entrepreneurs said they faced for
starting companies was one the cultural
barrier of Germany being risk averse and
more importantly the bureaucracy that
exists in Germany and I think those are
two things that the government can do
policy and top-down sort of measures for
making happen on the other hand I was
recently in Chile where startup Chile
has supplanted an entrepreneurial
ecosystem out of like tener basically by
incubating startups creating policy sort
of highways that kind of thing what is
the German agenda in terms of policy for
for improving entrepreneurs and giving
them more access to resources oh I hope
that you can see our companies can say
that we the German government and the
politics and the whole have a strategic
approach to raise our start-up scene to
strengthen it maybe we you mentioned I
think the question of money venture
capital we try to bring up the bigger
venture capital companies maybe from the
valley to Berlin to Germany this evening
we'll have a appointment with the bigger
companies from the valley and maybe we
try to invite them and they will come to
us and only once but twice and so on
want to make a bridge between Valley and
Germany especially Berlin then we try to
come to a better legal framework in
Germany in itself
you mentioned bureaucracy question - -
fountain company last very long maybe we
can shorten the period between the idea
and the real company and
that's not very easy because it's not
only the responsibility of the federal
level or me as a federal minister
so I've 16 beautiful colleagues where
the federalism it's beautiful but it
means sometimes some kind of bureaucracy
so it's it's a challenge so and we need
more employees and we're trained people
so that is reason why we try to to make
some advertisements in the global
economy to attract people to come to
Germany to work not only in the IT
sector but all our industry companies
but that is a problem but I know that
it's a problem maybe not in the valley
but in the whole global economy at this
moment but we try to bring up people and
money to German and we have a beautiful
basis good infrastructure at this moment
good educational system beautiful
companies perfect government every
single day nobody you're talking about
how cool Germany is but what about the
rest of Europe I mean Germany's economy
might be still okay even though the
depth is pretty impressive but how will
the whole European Committee influence
the German economy in the future I said
in my speech that the European Union is
some kind of family for Germany so it's
a question of solidarity if we want to
help yes No and Germany is a strong
economy as a strong country we will help
our neighbors our partners our friends
in the European Union and yes they have
problems as you know maybe with a budget
and much more with their competitiveness
so we have a special rule in Germany
that's called debt break and we brought
our colleagues
to make such kind of depraved in their
constitution 27 member states this day
after July 28 member states and 25 of
them have these DEP break now and we
tried to make reforms together on the
labor market in the social security
systems maybe in the administration and
to come to much more privatization
that's our approach in the European
Union not only German approach but it's
the approach of the whole European Union
and I think that's a very good idea to
reduce the lag and the depth to come to
better competitiveness and then you need
growth and we try to bring up growth in
the real economy in all our layer
partners we have some kind of export
initiatives with Portugal Spain Italy
and Greece and we want to have them so
I'm convinced that maybe if we hold
these way is cause I think in the next
10 or 15 years we'll be one of the
strongest economy region European Union
in the world because the problem of
depth is not only a European problem
maybe I read sometimes the newspaper and
I read something about the depth and the
fiscal cliff and the other things in
other countries and regions in the
horizon so I think that's a good way to
come to very stable European and not
only an economy what the hell you
European Union vice-chancellor thanks
for being with us here today so I
understand that's obviously been a huge
amount of growth in terms of startups in
Berlin over the last 5-10 years but
there are still substantial challenges
as I understand it between for startups
operating across the different European
countries and it there are still
challenges in terms of accessing your
present entire market so curious to hear
from a macro policy standpoint how do
you sort of address those those
challenges and differences between the
countries if the different
competitiveness is a problem inside the
European Union and what this problem we
know it from the beginning of the
European Union but because of the common
currency the euro there was no necessity
maybe no pressure to make some reforms
to come to a level playing field in the
question of competitiveness in all the
things I mentioned so now we are a
problem because of the debt crisis we
have in some Member States so we have to
come to the solution in the question of
the depth and then parallel we try to
strengthen the competitiveness in the
other member states and I think we need
time for this operation
maybe much time much more time than we
now have maybe 5 10 or 15 years but at
the end that is our common goal you want
to have level playing field in the
question of competitiveness and no leg
in the budget that's my Reem
this is the question about taxes it
seems that taxes around the world are
very murky subject and there's obvious
things we're finding out later that
people have been doing could you
estimate which country has the higher
taxes between Germany and United States
oh I'm convinced that we have higher
taxes and Germany but maybe it's a it's
a question of for politicians in Germany
and we against raising taxes so that's
aa member of the free Democratic Party
ah you are the second one thank you well
well warm welcome so but but maybe the
text in Germany much higher than then
then here in in in the United States and
we do not have only the taxes but we
have the fees for the social security
systems so labor is expensive in Germany
it's a problem but if you see our labor
market I think although we have some
problems it's very successful so at this
moment we have to find the balance
between reducing the debt and do not
raising the cheques so and that's a
position of my party in my government no
more taxes
yes I am one question and given the
current situation in many countries in
Europe and his perspectives and and also
coupling that with the policies to
restrict the costs around the European
Union
how does Germany and expect to create a
market for their companies all these
companies in the other member states
yeah okay so so first of all our part of
in the question of solidarity are the
mechanism to stabilize the European
Union we have ESM and so on huge some
kind of funds to say if they will have
horrible problems we want to help with
ESM and so on so you'll be in Stability
Mechanism and so we have that's the
opportunity for our member states for
our colleagues and friends to gain some
kind of time you want to use the time
for these reforms and we want to be a
market for them so we try to strengthen
the single market in the European Union
especially in the question of IT for
example and we import this year and last
year as well much more from our European
friends then we export especially to the
countries like Portugal also and we try
to bring them up not only to the German
market as a European neighbor but to the
word market so I have a good friend
who's Minister of economics in Portugal
and I said to maybe the next business
delegation we can make together and why
not because the European Union makes it
as well so maybe there is a small
opportunity possibility to help them to
find new markets outside Europe also the
European Union but we try to help them
inside Europe as well
yeah dr. Osler I came to the United
States five years ago I'm a German
American currently working here at Intel
in the valley and you indicated your
desire to bring back German talent back
to Germany I as myself I also have the
desire to come back to Germany but as a
tech worker I have to admit I really
like it here
especially from the financial
perspective I know that Germany has some
problems to attract for German
researchers back to the back to Germany
through special programs like as startup
funds to open up their own research
groups at universities but I haven't but
I'm not that quite aware of these
concepts or these programs for
industrial workers or high-tech workers
in the valley or in the United States
are there any plans or any ideas on this
to attract German industrial high-tech
workers from the United States back to
Germany with a huge internet platform
that's called the make it in Germany
make it in Germany and we try to attract
all kinds of workers we have not only
Artie but industry as well and we try to
bring up some special programs to come
to an exchange and in the end at the end
of this exchange that maybe foreign
students students wanted to stay in
Germany so you decided to stay in Valley
so if I understand you right okay very
sad but it's ok
okay okay so we have a opportunity to
the chance to do that you come we'll
come back to Germany okay so we have not
a special program for four but not for
IT but we have visas make it a Germany
and we have special colleagues in our
embassies it's a program now we have it
in India Singapore and I think in
Vietnam and we to try ring up young
students and maybe the pupils to to
Germany and but not engineers at this
moment but we try to come to a better
legal framework and the question of
foreign workers let's debate with my
friends and colleagues in the coalition
because I want some courage and welcome
in Germany for all people and there we
have different positions positions at
this moment but mainly after the
election
so I guess that's a question they're
also almost wanted to answer about dual
citizenships if you say you want to
invite people are coming to Germany so
does people have families kids growing
up but they kind of grow up in two
cultures right and now that at some
point they have to decide which passport
to hold it is going to change can we
hold two passports can everyone who's
coming to Germany do that and also
people come from Germany here can we
hold that as well I think it's
absolutely necessary that we have the
possibility to to to have two passes if
you want to come to - I think to any
country and if I think there's no
argument against two passes at this
moment but that's a question in my party
she is correct but but my my colleagues
and the other parties against these two
process at this moment but I think it's
a very strong signal and it would be
some kind of statement if you say yes we
have the possibility of having two
passes so much to do maybe you can say
to colleagues members of parliament yeah
do a nationality that's not
have pizza cancer many things that
you're here today with us I get many
questions here about the German energy
transformation the shift to green energy
and how it works compared to here you
know it just had a chance to sit in a
Tesla and see how startups play a big
role here in the shift to green energy
what's your view on the role of startups
in Germany and the energy transformation
and the role of the energy
transformation for the future economy in
Germany okay how many times okay so I
think it's a great opportunity for our
startup companies the whole energy
change our and a given because we need
grid we need power plants energy
efficiency renewable energy and for all
these we need IT for example if you want
to have not only the grid for the longer
terms but for the short terms you need
some special grid we call it smart grid
and we need companies for the smart grid
it's a question of IT we need much more
efficient power plants and not only in
the center of maybe our industry but
more decentered so we need some kind of
virtual power plant so we need IT and
startup for this as well we need more
energy efficiency and that is a part of
smart grid but is the question of energy
and using of energy in the whole and we
want to raise electro mobility in in
Germany and so the opportunity for all
our companies not only for our tea but
for the industry and all these parts
shows that there is a future in the
fusion between industry and IT and you
mentioned maybe the challenges in the
energy vendor and yes the problem is is
it affordable for the people and for the
companies yes or no and at this moment
it's very expensive the support of our
renewable energy is very expensive
if not enough time to explain it to you
but it's at this moment it's law which
has only subsidies the members of the
Parliament decides about the price for
kilowatt hour in Germany not the market
remember of Parliament's so so so that's
plant economy and not social market
economy and because of being a plant
economy it's very expensive at this
moment so we try to bring up a new law
to support renewable energy we want to
raise the part of renewable area at this
moment 25 percent in electricity you
want to raise it to 35 percent in the
year 2022 so we have much to do in the
question of the energy given about the
huge opportunity chances for our
companies especially in the IT sector
but in the whole industry it's all
optimistic the chairman of the free
democratic you must be optimistic barely
armed a better sexy I realize that one
of the problems that people have
nowadays is the gentrification going on
in areas such as no Cohen Prenzlauer
Berg and Kreutz Berg so I was wondering
how you see startups as helping solve
the problem of being a poor area of
Berlin being a poor part of Germany but
also preserving the sexy culture that
people praise about Berlin and yes I
said that Berlin is the synonym for the
German startup scene so we have in all
of our parts in Germany some kind of
startups in the internet seem so but
it's one part of our economy and and I
try to strengthen it yes because it's
important for the whole industry but
what we have to do anything in different
parts of the economy as well so I think
the best way to fight against poverty
poverty is to bring people and jobs and
all the other questions we mentioned
text
and raising competitiveness is to bring
the people in jobs and that's the best
measurement against poverty we have the
debate in village so it's a local
discussion but but but in my opinion I
think if we have companies and the
companies have richer people than the
people before and in the regional in the
area and part of Berlin I think it would
not be a longer problem because they
produce jobs as well in in the Inc
quarters of Berlin so I think it's a
it's a little bit funny this discussion
because they come to two more sexier
City yes but I think it's the goal is
for for every people and not only for
for hipping startup companies we need we
need to renew these companies and I
think Berlin needs these companies and
that there's a reason why I think the
Berlin government local government must
have an interest in modernizing the city
the infrastructure the buildings and now
they have a law that said that you are
not allowed to come to the nouvion
renovate your your own house or your own
apartment I think that's that's not
enough to five it
hi so my question is about the
immigration reform and as you all know
most of the growth in the valley was
because of foreign nationals being here
when they started a company and not
especially being that they came to the
to the valley to start a company so what
are there any immigration reforms on
your agenda that you're planning to
implement in the near future if you
would ask me as a chairman of one part
of the coalition and it's a smaller part
of the coalition yes because we need the
dual nationality and maybe we need the
possibility to come to us to study in
Germany and to stay in Germany after
you're studying and then you can found
for example a company but it's only a
short period you prolonged this period
in the last law I think when you go but
it's I think it might we need to shop if
you have major study maybe you need some
time to look around in companies and
maybe then you decide to file the
company of your own so I think that
would be a topic for the next reform and
then we have a structured system for
example in Canada which people are
allowed and welcome and which not so I
think we need some kind of off
structures structured system to come to
more foreign people in Germany dr. Saul
thank you very much for your speech I
have two questions the first one would
be of course the upcoming election what
your view and that is and also not just
what your wishful the wishful of como P
but also what would kind of be other
versions of a possible outcome of the
election that would not be the perfect a
copy for you but other possible ways
that you see for your party to be still
part of the part of the government and
the second question would be more
personal you mentioned like how it is to
get up every morning and and what your
vision you have for Germany but as some
of the Germans in the
in the room probably know you went for a
very difficult time kind of taking over
the leadership of your party and I can
also assume being the counterpart of
angle Merkin is probably not the most
easiest job in the world so what how do
you personally go for that tough
decision where you're like in such kind
of the center of all the publicity and
also positive and also very often the
negative publicity how do you do that
personally okay I think the first
question was was what happened after the
election okay yes obviously first
unpassed on secret no holiday Torah I
think we are in a very successful
coalition look at our figures and
numbers in Germany in comparison to
Europe or to the United States I think
we can be very proud of what we reached
in the last four years so that there's
only one position in my party we want to
continue this coalition and that is my
goal and they go for my party and
there's no alternative to this it's only
for me but for people in Germany as well
and and you I think you said it's not
easy job to be the deputy of chant
America yes maybe the easiest job in
Germany is to be Chancellor Mecca and
and and the second easiest job is to be
a deputy but you're right it was not the
the easiest time in the last two or
three months but it's a question of if
you're optimistic yes or no if you will
fight yes or no and so that if you are
entrepreneur you have similar situations
and you have to decide whether to give
up or to fight and I decided to fight
and now here last question
hi my father works at the one of the few
remaining companies in Germany that
produce solar panels so my question is
what you see for the future of solar
panel manufacturing in Germany thank you
yes maybe it's better to to look at
different sectors yes because in Germany
we have I mentioned the special law to
support renewable energy and they do not
support some technology they support the
people who decided to buy wind energy
power plants or photovoltaic power
plants or so for the last health so and
if you if you give subsidies to the
people not all the companies and maybe
for the research or so you will have a
problem because they forgot it doesn't
matter if you use Chinese solar power
panels or German photovoltaic cells and
because they are much cheaper than our
so so they used the Chinese ones and
that is not good and if you have a law
which said if you use now this law you
have the next 20 years every time the
same price it's very good for you but
there's no pressure for innovation
that's against every market law and so
the problem is that our photovoltaic
sector is not as competitiveness as
maybe other sectors in the world and
other regional words so I think it's a
problem at this moment and we have a
debate with a European Commission
because they want to come to to our
Muslim the punishment to do penalties
for the Chinese companies because of
their subsidies but the subsidies are
not the real problem
but the financing situation Germany so
it's better to to leave these
punishments and penalties because it
would be the beginning of a fight
between China and Europe and that's not
very good for you I'm convinced
especially in this situation so I hope
they find a solution thank you all for
being here and please join me in
thanking vice chancellor dr. Osler
another may have they all commit
vice-chancellor but to say the truth it
sounds beautiful vice chancellor but but
we have only the rule someone is deputy
of the ten-ton that's right that's me
it's an interesting position and but but
we have no uestions alike you have the
vice president vice president has no job
without being vice president and I'm
Melissa Foucault Novick so there's a
totally different position I'm very sad
about but it's ok sorry about that
I mean thanking on behalf of GSB in the
Stanford community thank you
thank you